[Applaudissements]
depuis plus de 28 jours déjà quelques
mirage me disent de faire le miour la
fée des je me suis tapant sur son
tambour les fantômes du syndic et
marchant de certitude se sont glissé
jusqu'à ma lune reprochant mon attitude
c'est pas très populaire le goû de la
[Musique]
solitude dans le
désert depuis trop
longtemps tu demandes à qui ça sert
toutes les règles un peu trué du je
qu'on veut jouer les yeux
bandés les fantômes du syndicat les
marchant de certitude se sont glissé
jusqu'à ma lune reprochant mon attitude
c'est pas très populaire le goû de la
solitude de l'autre côté voilà qu' un
toujours aussi lunatique son œil est
rempli de ça et ça bouche pleine de
verdict il trône sur un cimetière de P
[Musique]
mécanique es dans le
désert depuis trop
longtemps tu te demandes à qui ça ser
toutes les règles un peu truer du je
qu'on veut ser jouer les yeux
bandés les gens disent que les poètes
finissent tous trafiquant d'armes on est
50 millions de poètes qui doit faire
notre charme sur une lune de Saturne mon
perroquet sonne l'alarme c'est drôler
tout le monde s'en fou vendredi ton mon
nul par Robin son le solitaire tu m'a
dit je trouve plus mon île vous auriez
pas vu la
mer va falloir que je lu parle du thmon
nucléaireand es dans le
désert depuis trop
longtemps demande à qui ça ser toutes
les règles truc dis je qu'on veut faire
jouer les yeux
bandés es dans le
déseris
long la qui sa
ser les yeux
bordés hier un homme est venu vers moi
d'une démarche un peu traînante qui m'a
dit tu as tenu combien de jours j'ai
répondu bientôt 30 j'ai compris qu'il
espérait tenir jusqu'à
quand j'ai demandé son message il m'a
dit d'un air tranquille les politiciens
finiront tous un jour au fond d'un asile
j'ai compris que je pourrais bientôt
regagner ma
[Musique]
vie comp dans le
désert depuis trop
longtemps demande à qui ça ser toutes
les règles un pe TR du je faire j les
yeux
B
dans le
[Musique]
désert
dans depuis trop
longtemps demande à qui toutes les
règles un pe TR du je les yeux
B
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]